Hello, welcome back to this week's mental fitness episode.
I hope you enjoyed the meditation we did last week.
I think that has so much value for putting us in the right state of mind,
and we're going to talk more about that today.
So our topic for today is visualization and how important it is.
So studies show in everything we're doing, whether it's business, whether it's sports, in any psychology,
in any action that we take, 80% is psychology. 80%.
And 20% of it is skills, function, and training, talent, those things.
So we need to take our visualization, our state of mind, quite seriously, and improve it.
So I'm excited to talk about it and hear your feedback on how you've been making this a reality in your life.
So number one is ask yourself, how much are you visualizing good things?
How much are you thinking on good things, things that you want out of your riding,
things that you want out of this particular ride, things that you want that you are going after in the year?
How much are you thinking on those things?
If your answer is somewhere between, absolutely not, I've never done that in my life, I think that's crazy,
to I've done it once or twice, then that might be the reason why you're seeing less success than you want.
If your answer is a lot, then you're still not seeing the success that you want, maybe you need to do it differently.
And if your answer is yes, and I'm doing awesome, then good for you, and I'm very proud of you.
So visualization or changing your state of mind, not based on your situation, takes practice.
So I'm going to say that again, it takes practice.
Just like anything else, if you're building a muscle and you work out one day, it's not going to make a difference.
It's going to make a difference in your confidence that day for sure, but it's not going to build a muscle in one day.
And it's the same with any other skills that we're building. Visualization is really important.
So number two, the power of the mind is so great. It's so big, it's so vast.
And we know that in so many examples of how someone has overpowered some circumstance with a simple belief that they can.
Tons of scenarios where people are getting over things that they shouldn't physically be able to get over, and they do it with their mind.
So, you know, on a small scale, if you want to accomplish shoulder in really well today, you can do it because someone lifted a car over here or fought cancer or did those crazy bigger things.
So compare yourself to that and then realize that it's much more possible for you than you thought.
So when you're visualizing for riding, some kind of key takeaways or some tips are just make it very simple at first.
OK, so pick a movement or a course or a set of movements, and you're just going to imagine that you did them.
So you're going to close your eyes. You're going to imagine you did them, and it can be as simple as I'm trotting down the long side.
I'm balanced. I have all these traits and qualities to my trot, to my balance.
And then I make a circle and I do that twice. I change direction and do it the other way.
So you go through that might take you 10 minutes, but it's going to improve your ride a lot more than you expected.
So start simple like that. Good times to visualize are obviously before your ride every day. You can do it then.
For sure, before any competitive ride. So if you're out of competition, before your dressage test, before you jump around,
before your flat test, whatever sport you're in and what you're doing, before your cross country round, you're going to visualize.
You're going to close your eyes and you're going to imagine you're doing that. Once you get good at that, then I would encourage you to add your body in.
So you're going to you're going to need a stand in the trailer. You might look down from the outside because your eyes are going to be closed.
You're not going to be on the horse. You're going to imagine that you're riding this movement as well as move your body as if you're riding it.
So if you if you have a goal to give over this certain fence or to put your hands here or to make sure you kick your heel forward in this way
or keep your straightness or chin up or shoulders back over this part of the course or the movements or the pattern, then you do that with your body.
So you sit up on fence seven, you shoulders back for your shoulder in, look right for your leg yields, those kinds of things.
Do that with your body and add that into your imagining the movement.
So that's just some practical ways that we can visualize.
And I guarantee it's going to improve your ride even on the daily in competition.
And when you get that improvement in your ride, I'm telling you, it improves your confidence in your ability to make changes.
And when you can do it in your mind, your body will follow. And it's such a fantastic feeling.
So I'm excited to share this with you because it's been such an important piece for me and so many other people.
If you talk to any person at the top of sport or in the top of training or someone who just does this daily, they have they all visualize.
They all do some form of visualization and they're all seeing the improvement because of it.
So I'm really excited to see you guys do this and give me some feedback on how it went for you.